a alone offline or with a friend to  online co-op or buy a split screen there  are several unique types battles were  you and a friend go head to head  supported by a team of AI hear about ins  we face off as iconic characters like  Luke Skywalker and Darth Vader tribes  which push you to learn and master the  skills needed on the battlefield and  survival which are debiting here today  let's take a look  not my best  you made it thank the false we've  located your crash site but it looks  like the Empire will meet you first  prepare to defend yourselves until we  can get there  well god we've sent you a jamba we're  capturing this case  two of us closer  buyer is preparing to film everything  they've got at you  great work we've driven my dream  I wish I could see the Empire space  right now